you or someone you care about may have
been diagnosed with lymphoma
this video will help you understand more
about this type of cancer and how it
affects your body
your lymphatic system is part of your
immune system which protects your body
from infections and diseases
it's a network of organs and vessels
that filter the lymph to remove
microorganisms and foreign particles
the filtered fluid returns to your blood
lymphatic organs such as lymph nodes
contain a type of white blood cell
called lymphocytes the two main types of
lymphocytes are b cells and t cells
lymphoma is a cancer that originates in
lymphocytes b-cell lymphomas are most
common in the lymphatic tissue the
lymphocytes become abnormal and multiply
creating more abnormal cells that don't
work properly the two main kinds of
lymphoma are hodgkin lymphoma and
non-hodgkin lymphoma
the most common type of hodgkin lymphoma
is classic hodgkin lymphoma the cancer
cells in classic hodgkin lymphoma are
called reed sternberg cells and are
usually an abnormal type of b cells
these abnormal cells tend to spread in
an orderly manner from one group of
lymph nodes to another
non-hodgkin lymphoma usually originates
in b cells but may originate in t cells
as well
non-hodgkin lymphoma tends to spread in
a less orderly manner through the
lymphatic system
symptoms for lymphoma vary depending on
the type of lymphoma and where it is in
the body sometimes lymphoma has no
symptoms but in general the symptoms of
both types of lymphoma may include
swollen lymph nodes in the neck armpit
or groin
fever
night sweats
weight loss
feeling very tired and itchy skin or
skin rash
as part of the diagnosis your doctor
will try to find out the extent of the
disease and if it has spread
this is called staging
the stages of lymphoma range from one to
four and may vary depending on the type
of lymphoma
in general a lower stage means less
cancer growth
a higher stage means more cancer growth
the cause of lymphoma isn't known but
there are some things that can increase
your risk
being older in age
but a younger age is also a risk factor
for some types of lymphoma
infection with certain viruses such as
the human immunodeficiency virus hiv or
the epstein-barr virus having a weakened
immune system
and having a family history of lymphoma
as you deal with a diagnosis of lymphoma
continue to talk to your doctor and your
cancer care team